and I love having a mirror nice Jonathan
Tucker good to see you sir as I said a
thrilled to be here every time
appreciate I appreciate it right here in
uh Kingdom returns for third and final
season on 18 tees audience Network at
8:00 Eastern and Pacific tonight Jake
Alina who you play kid with a lot of
issues in the world of MMA is now in
real estate we just saw a scene with you
playing him not going very well no
there's some good they've done some good
advertisements around the LA where
they've got these bus benches that
they've taken over we've got my image
there and it said I will beat you into
submission I will fight for real estate
I just think that's just a fabulous
remark it is a great nice marketing ploy
right there
what's it like seeing yourself on a
bench like that I assume that's a first
it is the first yeah I know it's a lot
of fun it's a very it's very high-class
having myself there positioned on a bus
bench yes there is a fighter actually
recently who just won a fight and he
does sell real estate so yet when they
one thing he raised his arm this is
anything you want to say said yeah if
you're looking to buy a house in Long
Island give me a call terrific fighter
and if I was buying a house in Long
Island
you'd be doing that and so um now we'll
talk about your Red Sox in your pants in
a second I see you've got a cut over
your your eye on the right just to the
right of your eye looks fresh to me um
pretty fresh is less than 24 hours that
are sticking which is common annual pour
in Beverly Hills plus all it took good
care of me
I know him he's fantastic ninety minutes
from the time this thing was open to the
time it was sewn shut
beautifully under his eye with his hands
is the second good stitching he also did
this side yes the first season of the
kingdom when I took an elbow with J
thoroughbred harren who was in full
mountain dropped a nice elbow right so
these things are real as well yeah yeah
when you look the good thing about our
show that we're most proud of and this
is not just production or not just the
actors but everybody on the team from
prop and electric and grip to our DP and
in wardrobe is that we're honoring this
world that hasn't really been reflected
before and it gives it a sense of
nobility when you when you put in the
work that it takes to show what these
men and women and their families and
their teams and their coaches and how
actors and nutritionists what they give
and sacrifice to make a fight really
happen and sometimes that takes you know
it takes a little bit of jostling around
and we've all gotten a number of
injuries all of us on the show but
nothing nothing too severe and also it
gives it a good talking point when
you're selling your show premiering
tonight sure that it better you cut your
eye open though doing oh well this one
was for Entertainment Tonight you know
there are a lot rougher to making the
rich action show look pretty darn a week
out here and we could throw have a lot
more space in this house I mean your
your your your guests and and your well
we and your team we do normally have
asked our segment called who wears it
better I mean you know um and so it's
either you or I don't know we could go
anywhere with that one well so we were
till we we do this segment yesterday we
were just kind of doing you and us
barring cam counter in Madison and you
know I know where you live lost and you
know where I live so I'm waiting for
that nice bouquet of flowers he's a
pretty boy did you miss him very
handsome these reverse tattoos yeah this
well I don't want to give away the
segment okay so that but we did have a
nice jostle I'll say this the exclusive
on the rich Ison shows of the ETS camp
cam which is his segment going to be the
best one yet just in time for Kingdom to
reappear on 18 T's audience tonight at
8:00 Eastern would you make of the Bryce
Harper fight I was curious to know what
what where where that umpire was the who
is calling the pitches man he didn't
take a lighter we didn't do it you
didn't put a lot of effort in Buster
Posey the catcher stood there and
watched it on full just watch I know it
was really it was really disheartening
and one of the things I love about
baseball is that you don't have that
sort of you can bring your you can bring
your grandfather very young son you
don't have to see that sort of violence
and right look pitchers don't forget but
that was a flagrant pitch oh that was
just totally inappropriate in somebody's
light livelihood and their professional
careers on the line like that but some
does something needs to happen but
certainly not a fight like well I'm
saying you know let's let's make a rule
where nobody can come out of the dugout
and let's have a one-on-one fight if you
want to fight yeah it's you versus the
guy maybe no fights though well I mean
obviously but if we're going to have one
let's not have a pig pile let's get one
guy against one guy maybe they can they
can have an octagon that comes up from
the mid
of the turf that's actually a great I
will we subscribe to that I do that
would be fantastic I could but that's
not a sanction regulated fight you know
you've got like helmet magic that helmet
had actually gone where he had thrown it
you know he was annoying it to the side
you were bad throw a helmet good about
that guy's head open it was kind of
horrible it was horrible but uh it was
horrible throw yeah which is why I think
he should he should have gotten more
games is whatever the Smashville
throwing stuff on the ice you know I
mean never that was fantastic that's
maybe I mean I guess I'm a pen I'm a
Pamela Pittsburgh fan in general I don't
know I just love that town I think it's
like it's a great American town you know
the fans are so devoted and passionate
and there's no other town you see where
there's like a 45 year old female
attorney coming down for a smoke break
wearing a Penn's Jersey you know
well she's well too you know in the
middle of the day getting ready for the
game it's just a phenomenal I love
Pittsburgh and I love those teams so
that's a scene I'm sure that's playing
out right now on the streets of
Pittsburgh right around after lunchtime
for Game two that's tonight Jonathan
Tucker of Kingdom right here but how do
you square that circle with the Steelers
in the paper that's where that sir I do
maybe I maybe I'm too liberal in my in
my fandom but I yeah I've just always
liked steel town man oh my gosh feel the
Pittsburgh I like to rest will still
kick Cincinnati gas or Cleveland's I
feel the Pittsburgh steel and enough
stuff to push away that's true I was
just on vacation for five days my wife
and I went to a wedding we were in Italy
and I've walked into some shop some
small shop and a Domo you're in the
urinals we write we write we're but down
the street from the Duomo that's right
there and it was like some leather shop
or whatever where you can buy a jacket
or a bag or what have you and on the
wall this guy who spoke hardly a lick of
English a picture of him measuring a
suit a jacket for Franco Harris
fantastic on the wall and I'm like I
mean Steeler fans are everywhere yeah
there is look I like working-class towns
that really support their teams I put
Boston there yeah I put you know
Philadelphia in there as much as I don't
like the Eagles
I put I put Pittsburgh in there
don't put New York in there they buy
their way out other than obviously the
Mets and I like and I like the Giants
too but the teams that you support are
the teams that I think is buy their way
out of problems they're like tossing the
keys of the valet and calling a guy a
bad name and throwing a dollar okay
appropriate work okay um just when you
stand just when you thought oh yeah they
don't care whatever that there would be
no fisticuffs during this conversation a
nagging things we're looking good okay I
want to take a 60-second break come back
and talk a little bit more because I
would love to get your sense and what
everybody on your set thinks that Connor
McGregor may be stepping into an actual
square square ring the fantastic
audience drama Kingdom returns for a
third and final season tonight at 8:00
Eastern and Pacific and Jonathan Tucker
is here moments ago during our
conversation when you took a broad side
swipe at the New York Yankees before we
took a break Major League Baseball
reduced Bryce Harper suspension a game
he's now going to be serving just a
three-game suspension that starts
tonight so knocked it down from 4 to 3
Hunter Strickland suspension of six
games we don't know if they've touched
it so that was just the latest right
there now then if you think the Red Sox
aren't sitting on a freaking Fort Knox
spending money like their drunken
sailors on shore leave trying to win a
game and look at against the Yankees
look at their numbers don't say that
they don't count that you've got to be
kidding me I mean these just isn't I
mean it from my understanding and look
here that you're the sports no no it's
but I feel like aren't the Sox like the
fourth I spend what do you got over
there look it up there's something
called the internet right in front of
Chris Prosser Samba right if I am right
I don't know things but in all the
Yankees are spending their money you're
going to get you're going to take me to
the Raiders Patriot new game no no I
knew if I'm right and well hot I'll take
you
Los Angeles Dodgers are first this year
246 million they're always the pluckiest
quarter billion team in major-league
base near Yankees are second this year
without two hundred and two point three
eight eight million it's a rod still on
their payroll Boston Red Sox are third
two oh one point eight plays behind
right behind
we're Wars do you find the same yah I
said well I don't know about that I
think we're we're pouring our own gas in
the tank while you guys are having guys
pull up pull up and pop their hoses and
it's a totally different car
the breakdown is a hundred and thirty 1
million for the Yankees on the 25-man
roster 43 million on the DL 27 million
retained 3 million buried buried we're
in the sand I'm not sure in a rock on
recording wrong now I'm selling by cash
I mean they look at that they build this
new stadium they charge everyone a
fortune yet all these people who can't
go see a game and bring the family
anymore
and pay back is beautiful because
they're having a really challenging time
filling that Park for the Sox man it's a
beautiful way it's holy you can get in
there's some cheap seats still to be had
they don't have that luxury box problem
not corporate America in there that's
Boston can I write pitch in are you like
Philadelphia Washington collar town
that's my man right there well Jonathan
thanks for coming on a show I like to
jam a giant chin I like the Giants quite
a bit now what do you in the rest of
those on your set and your colleagues
who are is into the world of mixed
martial arts as you think of Conor
McGregor getting into a square ring
taking on Floyd medal everybody I mean I
guess I guess um where there's been this
pushback that it reduces the quality of
boxing as a sport I think that all came
out and said this but the fact is like
but the combat force has always been in
the vent it's always been a spectacle
and I don't know if we're going to see a
more extraordinary version of that than
Floyd Mayweather and Conor McGregor
getting in this in this in this scrap
it's going to be I think it's going to
be awesome
now are you of the mindset he doesn't
have a chance on us talking about the
sport is like and this is why it's so
hard you if you guys bet on on mixed
martial arts it's just it's nearly
impossible because anything can happen
this is not it's not but it's not MMA
here
I mean we're elbow bossing is I mean
boxing is that Conor's not going to be
coming in I think it's going to be I
think it's anybody's fight I think
anybody who says otherwise or they know
who's going to win or Connors never box
before or Floyd's to rolled or you don't
know the striking power hitting power of
Connolly nobody knows anything these
guys are in their own camp they're in
their own world the my game is the most
important part of it
and everybody wins they're both going to
walk away with hundreds of millions of
dollars pay-per-view is going to win
fans are going to win it's like a no
loss situation I'm really excited
I do love Conor McGregor's mind game are
the keys as good as it gets it's so much
fun just listening what comes out of his
mouth or on his Twitter account I just
like and what he's going to say about
you I think he's going to bring up
Floyd's past Floyd's history I think
everything's going to be fair game for
him leading up to this thing once it
finally does happen I make it really
person I love authenticity and this is
like why you go that you look to sports
you looked like great drama authenticity
it rings so clearly and loudly across
our species we're just always on the
lookout for inauthenticity you're
looking for someone selling you a used
car in a restaurant somebody in a
business situation you're everybody's
got these extraordinary detectors of BS
and when you find somebody at a very
high in public level who is completely
truthful it's it's wildly attractive I
love how you say that about how we're
always looking for in authenticity and
trying to call it out in sports we
really are especially like just throwing
out a latest example of it somebody
coming on the show accusing one team of
buying themselves a championship right
yet their team is only about a million
kind of a role in order saying so I
don't think yeah before max 202 to like
201 will change the fact that we weren't
talking about our numbers and yari
versus number two you guys are out
spending us that's just how it is just
the facts right it just whacked I think
it's just 27 over facts 27 overall I
don't think it robs your windows going
to win between my weather or Conor I
think an factually no who spends more
money every year consistently to buy
Championships with an attitude by the
way you can't quantify attitude although
than the Yankees you know did you have a
bomb I'd this happened over the weekend
to Bob Arum said if Mayweather doesn't
make the fight Pacquiao will do it yeah
I think I want to fight it so did you
hear that idea see that Wow
yeah he said if made what if Mayweather
is not interested Pacquiao will do it
yeah I don't think it has the same juice
I love Pacquiao I trained this a gym
with justin fortune who's one of his kin
ich Ihnen coaches do and pack has a
phenomenal fighter and he's an
extraordinary human being but I just
don't think it has the same residence
with fans as this Mayweather Mayweather
McGregor sure well one of the reasons
why kingdom works so well is the
authenticity of it just to bring this
whole conversation full circle and you
and Grillo and and Matt Lauria and Nick
Jonas and the rest of the crew they're
so great honestly I'm watching a real
privilege for us to be a part of that
and this is our final season and I think
all of us are walking away with our
heads up high because the fans of the
world the mixed martial arts
then the fighters and their families and
supporters I've said that we've reach
our bottom bar the bar the only one we
wanted to reach which was can we honor
them in their world and to know that we
have feels it's one of the great
privileges in my life yeah that's just
that the Ascension of the sport itself
it's been it's been perfect timing in
that regard thank you sir for coming on
any single crotchet and you leave you
leave unbruised unscarred unwatered yeah
it's big other than my ego hmm slightly
slightly battered by your Yankee by your
Yankee pride sir Rich Eisen shown
weekdays at noon eastern on radio
stations across the country and audience
if you like that video be sure to
download our app and I'll be sure to
help the NFL figure out what it catches